one two three four
[Music]
that's that sound that's that sound
amazing what's going on everybody how
are we doing it's it is even more
powerful in person well thank you thank
you did you did you hear salmon eyes
improv song last time I I'm really I'm
disappointed that he's working on other
projects today because I I think this
whole podcast should actually just turn
into a musical yeah let's do it
I can't sing but I'm down I'll totally
do it then you've never seen the
Hamilton alright I will finish Hamilton
at some point but it was late honestly a
musical about the American Revolution
sounds like the most boring thing in the
world I bet we beat the British are just
artistic people who love Hamilton so
much and I watched it I could not get
into it whatsoever I was like wow this
is the best community theater thing I've
ever seen community theater at the
highest level it feels like a community
theater production of like some like
narcissus like made this musical in
order to start himself yeah it became
like the biggest musical of all time
that's what happened well is it bigger
than cats yes absolutely okay really
I'd rather I'm going to write myself a
musical called Hamilton starring myself
as Hamilton directly my my Hamilton
whose name is Hamilton Hamilton I'd
rather see the Sponge Bob musical I'm
gonna say that right now can I actually
really want to see that movie
I mean musical I did find the the
showing on Disney of Hamilton to be
interesting and how they because they
very obviously had multiple takes bad
takes with a head like the camera on
stage next to the performer and whatnot
and it cuts together so perfectly
because it's like they have the entire
like two and a half hour play like as a
perfect take so imagine like having a
scene you're ready to record it and
you're like alright now go and they just
give you a two and a half hours perfect
yeah okay now for a different angle now
for this third angle close-up yeah like
multiple days - right I would have to
assume yeah because it's like imagine
what you probably only elections you
know I imagine you can only do one of
those things in a day yeah before the
actors are just like layer of sweat
would just be to imagine though if you
were like powerful that audience that
like was the Steadicam audience and then
you're just like oh great there's the
Steadicam guy in the middle of our
performance of Hamilton what a great
performance so I was wondering I think I
wanted to bet that all the performances
we see from that showing of Hamilton
there is no audience and they just
recorded the audience audio on one of
their showings without any camera
equipment I don't know how I know that
but I know that they did do one full
recording okay I mean I'm sure they
could have done that but not the one
where there's like a camera guy flying
through right yeah they did that was
like the classic backed off yeah thing
so right now right now they're they're
piping and sound from the audio from the
crowd in the MLB games right now
oh really yeah it's a little weird it's
a little weird I don't know like a
sitcom for sports I mean it's kind of
yeah there's like a sitcom track that
would probably sound just more familiar
because I mean I've seen like
professional wrestling right now where
there's nobody in the audience and it's
just like the spookiest thing to watch
it's like yeah date yeah UFC has no one
in the audience to right now and it's
and it's pretty eerie when there's like
a big move and then like you can hear
the trainers and stuff like yelling but
there's no there's no crowd somebody
should figure that out so we should get
on that and come up with an app where
people can just pipe in their audio and
then that gets piped into the actual
like arena and then just like output but
positive 48 like decibels just like
running into the audio oh god yeah yeah
they'd have to come up with some troll
vention mechanism but personally I'm
really intrigued by the return of the
NBA because they're gonna be filming all
of their games in one Stadium with all
of the teams present mm-hmm yeah they're
in Florida yeah yeah they're all like on
hardcore lockdown they're all practicing
together so it's like it's basically
just a giant NBA camp where everyone's
hanging out together and so yeah but
they're also still trying to be
competitive because you know these are
actual games that are on the line so I'm
really intrigued to see how that's gonna
play out well the weird thing for them
was that they they had to stop midway
through their season yeah so they
they're picking up their their play
records from March and then now
continuing with those play records for
like another I don't know how long
venez yeah I blacked out what sport are
we talking about it's July bad news guys
Ratatat not met
all right so today's topic is timeless
debates timeless battles of across human
pop culture and human history and we're
gonna go through our take on a few of
these and just you know just just go
with it you know we're by no means
experts on any of these topics so this
is all just for fun so for the for y'all
listening just come along have a little
fun with us and and tell us you know
what you think in the comments as as we
explore some of these some of these
simple but fun no matter what we're
gonna talk about I'm a complete expert
in that field and I am NOT wrong there
is one field I'm at I'm an expert in and
that's the field of today's sponsor
being sponsored by story blocks
actually legitimately love-story blocks
I use it on almost every video so we're
gonna get to that and I swear I'm still
a pro even though I said today's sponsor
is sponsored by story blocks I meant
today's episode it's okay we'll get to
that let's get to the first topic okay
guys first the first topic is a
relatively new one in human history in
fact it's about humans robots or humans
that's the first topic robots or humans
so you're just gonna show us a
collection of slides is it robot or is
it human what which one click on all the
squares that I think we can reach a
center point here cyborgs okay yeah yeah
cyborgs yeah don't don't immediately
Philly D this and go for the center
point let's talk about there's an answer
in the middle for everything happens
Nick if you had to pick robots or humans
robots robots robot human hybrids for
the sake of the game we play the game
just make a choice okay I like humans
I'm team humans yeah I like humans all
right I'm gonna go with robots then
that's to be - to be - yeah now now
robots here's the thing about robots
their their precision is is beyond any
human comparison and I think I think for
that reason alone
robots grin bro you ready for this
though okay yeah humans made robots so
they wouldn't exist without humans
consider the following in the future
robots will make humans
oh yeah and see that's a question
because it spec about you mentally
humans you need a robot to survive
already
we don't know I I mean robots a little
bit more like generically like machines
machines machines people are being put
on robots to survive that's really
mounted on
now hold on though because you can
survive without any machines or tools
you just would be a lower life-form
would be oh no deal devolved life Matt
don't do this what do you mean with
people with disabilities are not lower
life no I'm not talking about disability
what are you talking about monkeys they
don't use tools you were baiting me this
is this is how you win humans would
still survive I want to there weren't
robots but robots would also survive if
there weren't humans that's true I want
to change my answer to robots so that
any robots in the future watching this
podcast won't you know be angry at me
posthumously and oh wait what's that
called is there a theory for that they
went over this in Silicon Valley one
time Oh like yeah I know what you're
talking about it's not like robot
apologist it's like intentional feature
robot overlords a robot sim that's
always a simple ah yeah yeah you know
someday we're gonna have robot
girlfriends or boyfriends it's gonna be
it's gonna be a grand old time okay wait
wait okay that that brings us perfectly
into the next topic can of robot love
yes yeah problem yes not right now yes
not right now though eventually
eventually yes yes I mean love is just
an emotion and emotion is just a
pre-programmed series of synapses firing
in your brain that in essence can be
binary code that you can translate to a
computer just no one's figured out how
to do that yes we were theoretically
yeah - eventually emotion we're
eventually to emulate human emotion on a
machine then it would be for the most
part to our understanding exactly one
for one mapping of how the human brain
operates which the human brain in itself
is just a computer yeah
to meet computer see you think you think
the human brain is capable of being
broken down into absolute binary code so
it's going to be different than how we
understand it and also it's not
necessarily gonna be binary there's also
like quantum computing there's there's
all sorts of different like ways that
could be gone about it
we might be able to use like synapses in
the future like artificial synapses yeah
I mean yeah like electronic synapses
it's hard to understand how it'll end up
looking because no one's gotten there
yet
yeah but there's no like blueprint or
roadmap if it were an AI that were more
intelligent than us then ostensibly
it would be able to feel loved in some
sort of capacity even if it is maybe
just our preconceived notion of what
love is I think you guys have a very
pessimistic view of love oh but I think
Jake I live in Los Angeles of course I
do okay cellphone I got a text message
um thank you would you consider this a
robot Yeah right yeah I would it's it's
got robot like qualities I have Mike I
would say but it's a robot and a lot of
that robot assistant comes from I banded
that thought halfway through talking so
your phone machine learns for you your
daily like habits it can he it can do a
lot of thinking for you because a lot of
it is like automation and calendars and
a lot of things that you would normally
not be like having on your mind
constantly now that we've offloaded it
onto your phone so it is doing a task
for you therefore that's true and you
can sync it to different other
applications which then it allows it to
like capture information from those
other applications and input it into new
ones yeah it's pretty robotic so also
there's the fact of like you know Siri
or whatever ask Google is
what's that go-go system Google
assistant thank you and uh but none of
that processing is actually taking place
on your phone that's all taking place in
the cloud and your phone is just
relaying that information so right that
aspect of the AI aspect on your phone
your phone is just a vessel but the AI
is out there they're serious so maybe so
maybe we're just a vessel for love you
guys most like Siri doesn't work if you
don't have an internet connect
yeah yeah well that was interesting
okay let's move on I got one more wait
hold on Jake we didn't hear the opposite
side of this yeah exactly
sorry go ahead you're suppressing our
viewpoints right bad probably Matt go
for it man oh yeah I think I've said my
piece run what what is your on the on
the human side where are we still doing
the human thing I almost started doing a
Jane impression there the time frame are
we talking about here are we talking now
but like okay because if we're talking
right now or the immediate future I'm
humans all the way because humans are
interesting they do cool stuff you know
they're they have empathy they also have
stupidity which I would prefer a little
less of capable of very high highs and
very low lows and that's what makes us
very unique yeah
and humans build robot mic drop before
we go any further I got to tell you guys
about today's awesome sponsor story box
it's the one stop shop for all of your
stock asset needs that means After
Effects templates video b-roll audio
assets you look at the clips you say hey
I want this footage of the truck going
down the street I'm gonna download it I
mean I'm gonna put it in my video and
then I'm gonna upload my video and I
don't have to worry about a thing
because it's all royalty-free and it's
all super high quality meaning that you
don't have to worry about oh I can I can
I use this in my commercial or can I use
this in my podcast if it's all
site you just download it and you use it
and the best thing about the
subscription that they have is that you
can get unlimited amounts of downloads
and that's why we use it over here at
corridor because with a team across
multiple channels multiple editors
multiple people working on videos all
the time you need a place where you can
just go and have access to those sort of
assets and story blocks does exactly
that so if you guys are just amateur
video creators just looking to make
something for fun or if you're a
professional creator looking to improve
and add another tool to your toolkit
consider story blocks there's a link in
the description below or you guys can go
to story blocks comm slash corridor cast
to sign up that's story blocks comm
slash corridor cast anyway back to the
podcast and that was our sponsored
segment right there so thanks to story
blocks for helping us avoid a lot of
other jank through their high quality
premium slate of all the stock assets
you might need ok anyways guys onto the
next topic I think we've solved robots
and humans let's be human when the
process human assault this one evolves
the topic of humans and robots
determinism or free will it's Nats
favorite topic determinism okay wait
let's go around the room go around the
room determinism for that read free will
all right Matt but I don't know what
like this these are questions this is
the point this is the point like let's
just let's just go with it and just see
where it leads and just have fun with it
absolutely I maybe take a hybrid stance
because I can you know hybrids hybrids
that's called a third philosophy called
compatibilism and it's it's a hybrid
it's junk it's garbage I'm throwing it
away forget what I think okay fine I'm
going full-blown
determinism then all along
all right I'm going full vogue free will
okay well okay well okay all right who
wants to the sides of cross yes so every
interaction that ever happens is a cause
to effect interaction therefore from the
beginning of the Big Bang to now has
been a series of events that are either
random or just chaotic in such a way
that created all of existence that we
know now therefore our brains are
nothing more than meat machines
computers that are making input-output
responses based upon previous stimuli
therefore we have no free will because
everything is just a chemical reaction
that is a reaction from previous stimuli
so we do not have free will even if you
feel like we have free will because
there's no quantum state in our brain
that creates a physical reaction that is
any different from our preconceived
notions thoughts feelings normal norms
what-have-you see here's the thing
you're answering which one do we have
I'm answering I like the words free will
I like free love the lovely fluffy
little words but do you agree what
friend will he needs to be buried at
that like been incarcerated for too long
free will pretty well so okay so what I
close to the what about do you have a
choice what about when you have a
legitimate choice on something you don't
have a choice to wear a black shirt or a
blue shirt what that's a choice right
okay so the choices are predetermined by
you owning a black shirt or a blue shirt
therefore those are the limited choices
and you might have a predisposition
towards a certain kind of shirt built
into your brain that you do not know of
before you even start to take the action
therefore but if you don't know it then
it's like
but like matter if you don't know of it
so even if you roll the dice that would
still be a physical interaction of
certain like factors gravity inertia
what-have-you
creating your choice for you you're not
making the choice randomly your brain is
making that choice your brain is a
physical object that is making that
choice yeah so there's I mean yeah the
magical certainty that this thing is
going to happen 100% of the time based
upon predetermined codgers how do you
come up with preconceived notions
if stimuli over time so so check this is
a real-world example for you right here
I wouldn't have today I would not have
gone on the internet and looked up what
determinism is so that I wouldn't look
like an idiot on this podcast and I knew
what I was talking about if it weren't
for this podcast and I guess my own you
know self example though you made the
choice to do that make a choice but I
didn't though did I did I cuz I wouldn't
have looked that up at any other point
in my life it really didn't have the
normative will in order to be looking
things up yeah when he doesn't know what
the answer is so he has been
pre-programmed from an early age to look
things up when he doesn't know what it
is yeah so that I don't want them yeah
but you admit that there's normative
will no I'm still not admitting that
there's agency I'm saying that there's
generally a confidence in which he is
going to do this thing yeah and he did
it because of that general confidence
Jake Jake a real issue here is that will
has not met bail yet either goddamn hero
and it's a shame that we have yet to
free will free wheels on the back of
that shirt yeah enjoy the control the
good times by freeing will okay hold on
so there's no agency there uh probably
not no I feel like this is where you and
I might differ a little bit okay
three will is basically just a super
simplified extract of determinism right
because it's like if you're what you're
saying is true it's like everything is
preconceived but if you're too just like
crop out all of those factors and just
have it sure it's like the coat it's
like it's like learning how sausage is
made right it's like oh I want these two
sausages butter so I mean the
determinism doesn't say that you need to
behave as if there is no free will it
would drive you crazy for one because
then you would just be nihilistic about
every single individual thing like
what's the point of doing anything I
everything it's been determined for me
but I mean it is like a factor that does
start to like crop into people's lives
when they have like less options so I
mean like like being poor for example so
yeah there it's nice to think that we
have free will and that is in itself a
chemical reaction that is predetermined
but unfortunately we do not that seems
very conclusive of something that I
don't think you can really determine to
such accuracy Bree did you were you were
predetermined to think that in the
morning that's why you can never win
that argument though and that's that's I
don't know I feel like that's my problem
with it a little bit because like there
is like I don't actually believe that
everything is predetermined if there's
only like one set path that you can go
unless that's not what you're saying
then would you say that you do actions
by random at any given point in time no
I just I guess my free will doesn't
imply randomness though yeah I have to
or else your or else you're like just
factoring in predetermine like preset
factors well let's talk about this let's
talk about the shirts okay
cuz the personal shirts you have the
black and the blue shirt and the black
shirt B of the agency to determine what
shirt you choose this can factor in like
what your favorite color is does it
match this outfit these are all factors
that are already inside your brain from
yes yes but you're right but your
choosing you're not saying okay how
about this how about this I come to you
and I have two different shirts I have a
red shirt and a blue shirt which one do
you choose
probably the one that my brain says
which one I'm sure a blue shirt yeah
which one do you want yeah we have to
get will a shirt okay so probably a blue
shirt okay I hand you the blue shirt you
uh you just made the choice to choose
blue based on all these inputs and
variables going on behind the scenes
that in entice you to make that choice
that you don't realize but in the moment
you're not thinking about that and you
chose blue so it doesn't matter if I'm
thinking about it because it's still a
chemical reaction that but your choice
is agency it's not agency it's the
appearance agency no it manifests agency
literally in this you know you have all
these predetermined things that lead up
to that choice and then you make a
choice so I still have less agency than
if I had every shirt color I know but
that doesn't matter that the fact that
the fact that you have a choice at all
implies that you have agency in assess
no it doesn't okay let's move on well
hold on hold on real quick like let's
say in this scenario with the shirt
thing right we'll right who you're gonna
give the shirt to because he's he
doesn't have a shirt the man needs a
shirt get the manna shirt um you know
that we'll likes blue right yep so that
is a predetermined thing that you you
have to make that choice right that is
one factor that's an example of how it
could be a predetermined thing that is
not a choice because you're gonna give
that shirt to will and Will's gonna get
mad if he wears a red shirt he's not a
red guy he's gonna make the choice to
give will the red shirt no one can't
because all choices are just a cause and
effect what's the difference between a
choice and a decision okay listen just
hear me out
cuz you keep shutting me down when I'm
getting no your talk you're talking
about all these all these inputs that go
into the brain that are predetermined or
preconceived but then you take all of
those and from those inputs you
extrapolate a decision based on those
inputs and the simple act
of then taking the inputs and make an an
adding to it and making another decision
based on those based upon those inputs
is of the will it's of the mind no it's
your reasoning which is a still a
function of your brain because it's a
cost to affect previous stimuli have
factored in a a B so here's another
question does that line of thinking mean
that there's no such thing as a
multiverse of possibilities
that doesn't that doesn't say that
there's no multiverse it just means that
within the specific universe that we're
in and it's always going to be this
factor okay and in fact it actually kind
of strengthens multiverse because then
oh well first of all if we had agency
that every single individual choice that
we makes would create another multiverse
constantly that's kind of what I was
that's true though
well if we had free well but we don't so
okay okay okay you just saying that
though you're just saying it and just
because you're saying it's true do I
have free will though what's that
you still have an affirm that we do I I
have that's my in my example when you
when you take all the inputs and then
say you have a choice between the red
shirt and the blue shirt for will
himself as you choose the shirt for will
that is that is a that is the
manifestation of choice which is agency
you're taking all the things that you
know and you're making a choice of
rationale which is a function of your
brain it's not it's not entirely a
result of rationale though because you
might choose to give will the one shirt
one day and you might choose to give him
a different shirt the next day and those
and that might be based upon the exact
same factor we'll only likes blue he's
not gonna like a red shirt one day he's
not just gonna be randomly like yellow
so actually the fact that I can make a
different choice from day to day doesn't
preclude that I have free will it just
means that I'm going to make a different
choice but if you if your choice is
based entirely on rationale then where
does that how do you explain that away
okay Jake here's an example so let's say
I have a machine that can reliably throw
a ball and I know
that machine is going to reliably throw
the ball in the exact same spot every
single time so then I can extrapolate
the trajectory of that ball every single
time is that not just going to be the
same thing every time
well it's like the Sun rising but it's a
mechanical reaction that is going to
reliably happen every single time now
well extract a kit every single atom in
your brain and how it interacts then
it's going to be that your chemical
reactions to things that are the same
every time though what you know I'm
sorry your brain your brain your brain
has chemical reactions right that make
up yeah make up your response to all
these things did the the mixing of those
chemicals and the reactions that results
are not the same every time even if even
if the thing that you're basing the
reaction on is the same like the Sun
going around the earth every day right
but that strengthens my argument because
I'm saying that all choice or illusion
of choice are chemical reactions from
day to day state to state moment to
moment yeah but I think that's that's
just saying that I don't I don't
understand like why okay do you disagree
with the notion that that that the okay
so you have you have okay this is this
is like strict materialism right so the
thought that all things are physical or
chemical reactions with each other or
you have like the substance dualism kind
of idea where your soul is doing like a
is imparting its will upon the physical
world and then that is your your choice
like there's there's only really that in
how like you can view it because
otherwise everything is just you know
the pure physical interaction of your
body and all other bodies in this world
so like is it does your brain operate
outside of the rules of physics or no
because if it does all I'm saying is
there's things about the brain that that
are certainly beyond humanity I mean the
brain is built upon all these different
hierarchies of evolution to begin with
right and then there's things about our
own brains that we don't even
necessarily know so I think to just to
just write off that you have agency
because there's the obvious nosov things
that are causes and effects doesn't
necessarily explain the whole that's
that's all I'm saying and that is why
I'm an engineer we can talk about that
all day but let's move on I've got
plenty of topics okay ready war or peace
war or peace that's what about some sort
of hydrate no hybrids only a little bit
of war it's really a light dusting of
war like how do you use a pepper so I'm
gonna choose peace because that seems
like the obvious answer obviously I want
peace I don't want war but at the same
time war has been the biggest economic
driver in developing technologies and
furthering the world's things and also
we live in a world where there is good
and evil and it's you know that's a hard
one so like obviously the rule for me it
would be peace because war is horrible
and ruins entire nation states it's like
an average Tuesday but I mean has a
utilitarian I have to also state that
there sometimes are benefits to one
state over another
because of war but also generally it's
bad so what is your deterministic
viewpoint telling you to say right now
Jake my brain says peace okay so we got
two for peace Matt what say you know
ones and zeroes podcasts right no we're
in the middle o peace I love it it's
great all peace ok these all the time
I gotta be the odd man out then and save
war I know you would I know for the sake
of debate I think Jake the problem is
anything you say I don't think I will
disagree with it so it's kind of like I
don't know how to debate you on it
because that's the fun of this though
for sure a little would tell you guys a
war story okay okay wow this one time
when you were knocking centuries ago I'm
the only one who can say back in man but
there was there was a tribe of people
and they were all at peace okay and they
were all they were getting along and
everything was good okay
but then boom one of them decided to
make war on another one and from that
the entire circle of their peace was
broken and it all went away because they
all realized that war could disrupt
peace but then oh my god what happened
next
could peace disrupt war mm-hmm I don't
know I don't know could it Jake tell us
how does it end how does the story end I
don't know if it does end but I was just
actually say I would I would take wrens
argument though and I would say that war
has driven more technology than than
anything though it's hard to really
advocate for war because yet it's you
know I'm not I'm really just doing it as
an argument but I like we're also like
when you pose it that way
war or peace it's like well which one's
worse war
Wow yes yes worse than peace which ones
better but so the questions weren't
posed it was just war or peace I don't
know how much I can like marry it like
good but like you know war has destroyed
horrible geez would you say that it's
necessary though because that's the
times in history it has been necessary I
think it's the easy way so I think I
think there's a whole lot of wars
especially perpetrated by like the
United States that have been very very
deliberately trying to disrupt peace in
other countries so yeah well there's
also that happening against us too
all over true they love to do whatever
they're doing the easiest way possible
and war is so much easier than peace
yeah I would agree with that yeah that's
that's that's a good a good succinct
answer for it I think let me ask this do
you think we could have stopped Hitler
without war no that's my thought no damn
if I had a time machine could we have
stopped Hitler without war yeah well I
mean one way it would have been to
dissolve treaties that would have
created the entanglement in the first
place that would be done with diplomacy
but I mean at the same time he was like
still killing like 12 million people
aside from like yeah the total like war
costs so I know you could probably CIA
it and yeah isn't that form of
aggression still a type of war yeah did
with Russia for its more still doing
information war like a battle I guess
but like it's not not like necessarily
war we did that then like all people
would be at war at all times it's your
own strike Hitler well I think that's an
important point thing to point out
nad and that's like you know even even
in the greatest wars that it that
consumed the most lives and that were
the most hazardous to humanity in total
not everyone was at war during those
wars yeah and so you know there is a
there is a the thing is is that it's
it's not it's it's I know I'm posing
this in like a in like a bi you know
you're the one or the other manner but
you know like war just like peace is a
state of an individual being right and
you can be at war with one and at peace
with another at the same time well also
how we view war is kind of like in this
moralistic way that presumes like
rightness based upon results so like
even then like what we did so the
Japanese was horrible oh yeah and what
the Japanese did to the Chinese was
horrible and what the Germans did to
literally everyone was horrible and so I
mean there's no like positive answers
there like it seems like I mean I I
don't want to like do a quotation
because I would be horrible like that
that just doesn't stand like the United
States was not worse than German yeah
but it it also creates scenarios in
which like when you justify everything
you've lost like parts of your morality
and that's just like how war like breaks
down like moral systems in general like
so yeah it's it's it's worse than like
just like simply the deaths it's also
what it does to your moral systems and
everything that you believe and how you
rationalize things so yeah it creates as
a whole the whole and any whole anything
and this is enemy vs. but you know that
it's it's I think it's it's it's a human
issue you know I mean like obviously
there's there's other animals that fight
and cause war on one another but like
the complexity of it I think is inherent
to to humanity itself I don't I don't
know if it's something will ever escape
I think well there will always be forms
of warfare amongst humans
as long as we are a species you know
because that's that's the the way that
we that's the way that we are I mean
even debate is a form of warfare
depending on how you look at it no I
would say war rises to the level of
actual violence with the intent of
murder I think though what threshold is
aggression become war you know like
language when you see like if you can
have language can be violent it just
can't be it's not necessarily war like
language can incite violence language
itself isn't violent okay so Jake okay
let's say like I recruit like a bunch of
people like to kill you I'm like up to
the up to the point at which you get
stabbed is not violence like no it's
it's like the act though there's actual
distinction there I think like there's
that it's not self-evident that like
words are violence like the that's where
that's why words and violence are two
separate things you know words can
incite violence if you if you if you use
words to hire a bunch of people to come
after me then that those would be words
now they could still be illegal it could
still be prohibited but you know at a
certain point it would rise to a level
of violence and that would be that that
would be the threshold between violence
and words so what about the Cold War
there was no violence there oh there was
I mean okay sure in like but like
overall the word there was no like
troops on the ground there wasn't any
like battles in the cold well that's why
we and that's and that's why we used
that's why we use the term proxy wars I
mean Vietnam was a proxy war between
Russia and the United States
okay fair but but they but there was
where was violence and there was warfare
going on I guess what I'm trying to say
is like the idea of having war is that
there's a winner unless it's a stalemate
but like I guess that's going back to
what I was saying about debates is that
you know in a debate usually there's
like a winner and it's it's it's
gamified in a sense that like you know
you're trying to beat the opponent and
in a war that because war isn't just
violence violence is just Ned
this thing right wars war is very like
targeted violence also that there's
there's violence that doesn't
specifically involve like physical
interaction upon a person like so if I'm
if I'm doing something like political
violence which is violence then I'm
still doing violence but what do you
mean by political violence
okay so political violence is in an
action upon somebody else with the
implicit threat that if they do not do
it then they are subject to violence so
it is still in itself a form of violence
it's just that the the choice to a bad
choice I mean that's all in quote quotes
and choice to do it is effectively null
so well I guess what I'm saying is like
if I say like hey convert religions or
die I'm still doing like a violent thing
if they can conform to my will well once
you commit the violence you're
committing the violence right like it's
if before that it's you we use and we
combine it with another word to imply
that it's quasi yeah violence versus
just violence so as a threat not
violence I think a threat is violence I
think I think in itself a threat has to
be considered violence because like
otherwise like is it not really
aggression yeah of course it's it's
violence I think that says I think
that's a bit of a slippery slope I think
cuz because if you if you if you imply
that everything that is not the physical
harm of another against their will is is
is is violence then you can say like
almost anything that leads to that is
violence which isn't the case because
there's there's there's reduction
factors that can happen before that time
you know so like if the to take
political violence for an example you
know if I say or religious violence like
in the context that you're saying like
if I save convert to my religion or I or
you will die
that is
of violence but it is not the actual act
of violence yet
it has not arisen to that yet that's
that's how I think those words actually
have those words actually serve that
particular purpose when when we apply
them in our speech like that's why we
need to we would need to create some
sort of quasi term like like religious
violence or political violence or threat
prior to the actual act of violence
so I disagree with this premise because
there's like multiple forms of violence
that have been enacted upon people that
have been political in nature but have
mostly just displaced people or
disenfranchised people and those in
themselves are like under duress of like
being killed so like like Native
Americans being shipped across the
country like is a form of violence like
it's the Trail of Tears is violence I
mean it was explicit violence but it was
also political violence I don't know
people trying to form like ethno States
is that's violence that they say that
there's like the option yeah like to
leave but I guess what I'm trying to get
to is is if you think about you know to
go back to the war word you know at the
actual you know everyone would generally
agree like the definition of war is
organized combat against you know two to
two organizational units against one
another maybe that maybe it happens at
the individual level maybe it happens at
a group level what have you but but in
that and when we talk about winners and
losers in war you talk about life and
death right as whoever is able to kill
versus be killed is the definition of
who wins that war in in the in the most
specific sense of what the act is and so
I guess what I'm saying is we should be
we should be mindful about the words
that we use when they're not necessarily
tied directly to that life and death act
one-to-one you know when we cross the
physical threshold
just saying it's a natural threshold
within the context of language to
identify like words like violence and
things like that now I'm not saying that
the Trail of Tears didn't have actual
violence or that you maybe not or that
you couldn't necessarily describe the
activities that happened there as
violent but there's also other words for
it too you know like like you said words
like I'm using political violence is
disenfranchisement and undermining and
you know things like that are also
accurate words to describe the things
that happened there you're right Jake
I choose peace peace all the way okay
but I guess the point there is just like
you know we should like categorize
violence yeah it's like why there's like
specifically there's these
categorizations of what kind of violence
or like political balances and stuff
like a totally to separate like distinct
violence from like physical violence
like violence is theirs I mean well
there's a book called violence if you
want to read it well actually how is the
word violence interpreted on Wikipedia
it says it's got a couple different ones
let's see first one noun behavior
involving physical force intended to
hurt damage or kill someone or something
here's another one strength of a motion
or an unpleasant or destructive natural
force and then in law the unlawful
exercise of physical force or
intimidation by the exhibition of such
force so seems like it it obviously
trends towards that that line of
physical force but no it's actually
vehement is actually part of the word in
Latin that's interesting Wow well that
was a good one
next one what do you know x-force Jake
okay nature versus nurture okay and
let's make sure that we don't get back
into free will and determinism
yeah but nature versus nurture I can
give you the definition of determinants
I looked it up we look it up I didn't
look up nurture so I got a this is a
hard one because prominent psychologists
all agree that it's a mix of both
factors so it's an animal hybrid I guess
yeah I guess recognizing that if you had
to pick one as as the ultimate force in
the universe
which one would you pick nurture
probably okay read call of duty we're
not talking about Cod that your head in
the game bro so yeah so nature implies
some sort of like higher force right
what would you say is the most
influential force in the universe nature
or nurture
well I imagine there's probably a lot
more nature than nurture in the universe
oh that's a good point that nurturing is
part of nature it's true so that's
that's true okay I've changed my entropy
convinced me now what about you Matt
what do you say well I mean that just
convinced me that it was definitely
nature because made robots you can't
have one without the other you know I'd
have to go with nurture on this one
because thinking about it that way you
know you think about even in the natural
world there's all this nurturing that
that has to take place in order for the
natural world to even exist in the first
place right like a like a bear cub it
needs to be nurtured in order to
understand how to survive in the natural
world yeah but that bear cub wouldn't
have been born if it weren't for nature
for nature that's true hmm so but even
but even that even the process of the
bear cub being brought to birth is like
the mammalian womb is a process of
nurture chicken-and-egg I feel like this
is a chicken and egg deal isn't
I mean I don't know guys weird where do
we drop here's a here's a question
within this where do we draw the line
where nurture like if you talk about the
Big Bang Theory
where did inertia begin in that process
or did it was it at the same time it's
to presume a beginning but were those
atoms nurturing were they rubbing up
against each other and our entire
concept of what nurturing is is socially
constructed from just the things that we
do in nature so really yes yeah that
seems like that that seems like a like a
I don't know I don't know pretty to be
like but that's that seems like a big
statement that our entire concept of
nurture is based on social construct
what about like the way that ok so
there's some like parents I guess that
use negative reinforcement to their
parents reinforcement but both of those
things are what we would call nurturing
a child in some way but they're both
like at odds with each other so those
are both like socially constructed ideas
of how to nurture a child I mean they
don't give will a pillow in a jail cell
so he doesn't get any nurture he needs
nurturing and the yeah
I don't know if they're necessarily at
odds with each other all the time I
think sometimes they work in Simpson
together yeah yeah in tandem I think
because if you if you were positively
reinforcing a child only that might not
address like some of their you know some
of their faults it might it might create
some faults just as the same time as if
they were if you were constantly
negatively reinforcing a childhood so it
certainly do the opposite of like
positive like results versus like
positive actions because positive
actions are just like any action that
like ads versus like negative
reinforcement is to take
something away so what I'm speaking more
of is like parents who do what we
consider like negative things their
child versus like parents who do like
you know more like open or like positive
things right so okay are both nurturing
but they're in their way like they're
dialectical from each other they're
they're let's do an example so they're
socially constructed ideas of what I got
an example what if you have like really
angry breakup sex or something and you
and you know you get pregnant oh and
then you have the baby right and then
you're like oh I gotta give this baby up
that's not very nurturing I don't think
it's more nature that's full-blown
nature I'm so like what nurture would be
in the argument because there is a lack
thereof oh you're saying and that's
that's what that baby still grows up
though right
right but I guess what you're saying is
zero nurturing is silly form of
nurturing in the example provided yes or
I mean in like the conversation of what
is nature versus nurture yes mhm
without like it's what about like what
about like when to talk about the
positive versus negative reinforcement
of a child thing like what what about if
if you if you deny a child like say say
like you can't have this until you
finish your dinner
like a very classic example like that's
negative reinforcement is just negative
reinforcement to get them to a point
where they you can then use positive
reinforcement so is it positive or
negative reinforcement because this is
the de Leite you're what you're trying
to say is like you got to finish your
dinner then you get your snack right and
then what it has to do with nature
versus nurture because in nature versus
nurture your the argument is over the
result resultant like example of a human
being how they came to where they are
right now how they came to here whether
it be by their like genetic or like like
metaphysical nature or
a village raise them nurture so how a
child is raised is not necessarily
anything but just like considered
nurture in that example so I it's it's
irrelevant to the question unfortunately
no there's also well okay so they wait
well you are you're like a biological
being and that is nature yeah right so
so we can we can't deny that like
there's it's not all mate it's not all
nurture we're all space dust well okay
so is the question
someone's innate biology versus the way
that they are raised I believe there
wasn't an actual question yeah there
wasn't an actual question I just wanted
to debate the merits of what we're
talking about okay anyway here's a good
one here's a fun one okay this is kind
of you know this is kind of my
concluding one here clothing or
nakedness did it Matt you seem like
[ __ ] naked all the way party take it
all the way no no those do so much for
you they protect you like from the
elements I feel like it's an important
thing that we as like you know evolved
humans that have shed our layers of fur
you know I feel like we need it to
survive in this harsh environment yeah
yeah I feel like wow we kind of figured
it out we were like yeah if I put this
form of skin between my butt and the
ground it's not as hot
it is also eventually turned into a form
of expression yeah
so I'm clothing all the way I'm clothing
all the way oh man I thought what are
you guys is that least gonna be bacon
sorry it's alright Jake I almost did it
for you
right now all right let me give you some
more given come on Iggy Jake let's get
the nudists argument from Jake yeah okay
you get your only balls
we were we were born naked so what does
that tell you that was born in a super
tie unless your John Henry in which case
you were born with a hammer in your hand
butt naked is how we were born so
there's that I mean right away you know
the universe is telling us hey you
should probably be naked we're born with
clothes on and then second of all is a
naturalistic fallacy or the nature istic
fallacy he's naked because he chose
clothing think about all second of all
think of all the fun things that have
happened while you were naked
hmm I've changed my mind Jake more than
when I'm clothed that's and and in order
to make more naked babies you have to
well you don't have to be naked but it's
a lot easier if you're naked
yeah parts certain parts have to be
naked for sure but is that naked then
what's the definition of naked is like
also why is everyone always obsessed
with with trying to get people naked you
know it's like no one's ever encouraging
you to put more clothes on it's like
every everyone everywhere is constantly
like take it off take it off right so
yeah Marty Grameen you know yeah it's
like it's it's almost like there's an
inherent desire of human beings to be
naked
rather than of clothes but that's the
more I feel like maybe that's like
constructed from now we are all clothed
and we're all like hidden you know but
who sorry when they're not in their safe
space you know you only want to get Nick
have you been to Bourbon Street have you
seen a street when you do you get naked
and run across a football field you're
certainly not in your safe space
damn right so I mean most people aren't
most people aren't wait Jake
that Jake have you done have you done
the streaking question no I haven't I've
never struck oh man yeah this podcast
was just getting good fun fast yeah well
I hey cross-country runner and that's
basically like running around naked yeah
you still shorts on you're so shorts
that are about this big I did lock my
friend out of the house naked once he
was like changing and and we I think the
worst thing I've done to a friend in my
life oh yeah yeah intentional yeah yeah
yeah I'm sure this was when you were a
young man
yes yeah young and dumb yeah yeah that's
that's the only acceptable time about
six months ago well we all know the
arguments for clothes obviously there
you get a bunch of utility out of them
you can stylize and fashion eyes
yourself with them right yeah you can do
that do I have any other purpose other
than utility and expression utility and
expression other than that I mean I I
don't know I don't think so
I don't think if it came down to those
two things I don't think we'd wear
clothes but maybe you could make an
argument and there is an argument out
there that there is a sense of of what
do you call it like exposure in the
sense that you are when you're naked
you're all of your weaknesses are
metaphorically and physically like you
are weaker than another person who has
clothes on because you know obviously
you're exposed so seeing Terry Crews
nudists believe the opposite though so
that's kind of interesting what are they
what do they say maybe we should switch
I'm generally nudists I do like have
like recreational clubs I think that's
how they generally do that but their
opinion is that when
you are free of clothes then you are on
equal footing with every single other
person because you cannot tell anybody's
class yeah but also that you feel like
this kind of like freedom from I think
that's maybe that's the same thing
though cuz you know like you're you if
everyone is naked together then we're
all we're all exposing our our physical
and metaphorical weaknesses to each
other and I think that that I think
that's kind of the same thing Wow
so three three four clothes me for your
nakedness I guess I guess I'll be the
nudist even you'll be naked Jackie forth
yeah
yeah no worries
all right well that was fun on that note
goodbye I want to have any others any
other classic debase we should leave
toggle me for next time a question as
old as time one will XR or pint I mean
you guys there's no debate make an
argument for a pint I'll make an
argument for a pint just just for the
sake of it that's what it does it's
cheap if it's cheaper it is it's easier
to carry not that you wanna click here I
can afford yeah the best one wheel is
the one that I don't crash horribly from
which is none of them so yes the wind
that's yeah that's I mean that's that's
kind of it your answers inherent to like
which one's better cuz the one you can
afford like obviously you you're gonna
want the XR but at the same time if
you're just starting out you know maybe
the pint but at the same time if you're
looking at it long-term then I gotta say
XR I think we're obviously nationalize
our purchases why did I spend $2,000
over friends then it's gotta make better
thousand dollars and repairs since then
yeah I know how you feel hey tell us
about your fall red can we wrap this up
why are you telling us about
your fall oh yeah so I don't know if you
saw it earlier but I dipped my head back
and I couldn't lift I cannot lift my
head right now I have whiplash my just
pulled your hat to lift her head you had
to use your hand you've like hurt your
neck in the past two weeks because you
also oh we haven't talked about that i
clotheslined myself I'd rather talk
about that then my one will fall I had
yesterday falling off you should I my
camera's rolling when I did that so
village we did some airsoft games out
there a week and a half ago at this
point and I was running along and I
didn't see this this yellow rope it's
it's it wasn't very big but maybe like a
quarter inch half inch thick strung
across at about neck height and it
literally took me off my feet I was
running and it hit my neck and I had too
much momentum to stop and it literally
lifted me off my feet and then I dropped
down on to it using just my chin and
eventually slid off of it and left me
with this huge scab across my Adam's
apple here on my neck and it literally
it's only just now started to go away
you still kind of see a red mark here
yeah but the scab is gone away is really
weird scattered right up cartoon it was
like it's it was the most intense
rugburn yeah it was a rope burn you know
is wasn't quite like bleeding but it was
like super gnarly red and it got like I
got this really thick scab for a week
there and it was really really weird
is it gone yeah there's a scab gun we
should put that on a note and maybe note
that the stuntmen they say if somebody
injures themselves on camera yeah you
have to use the there you go yeah put
that one in put that at the beginning of
the next stuntman Ram yeah how do you
think they did this looks like a guy
that ran into a road I think he just
went for it
you see the way heat falls he's got to
be on a wire there's nobody that's got
to be real that's got to be real there's
no way you just can't do that you know
any other way that one day by the way
was so much fun that was like that was a
blast
it's pretty fun I love shooting out
there always always a good time yeah
that place is gold and I can't wait to
get back there next time I'm back in LA
oh yeah well thanks for guys for joining
me this was fun and I hope I hope it
spurs on many positive and productive
conversations in your own life so
chicken vs. egg which one put it in the
comments we have know pretty well that's
my man that's my boy right there
alright till next time peace see ya